Let's get another example and this time will be quite a bit more specific.
We already wrote a random tester for the little bounded line queue data structure
and one thing we might want to ask ourselves is "Did that further do a good job at all?"
Well, if you wrote a queue and find all the type of the bugs that I seeded in the queued data structure,
then you probably did a pretty job but let's take a look again.
We're going to do is we're going to look at the queue as a finite state machine.
We're going to see what kind of states we can drive that machine into using the random tester.
We're going to start off with an empty queue and 50% of the time, at this point,
we're going to make a dequeue call, which is going to fail, 50% of the time,
we're going to enqueue something resulting in a queue containing one element.
Okay, from here, it should be pretty obvious what could happen.
We can dequeue something going back to the empty state
or enqueue something going to the two element state unless it is assumed that that's full.
And so, the dynamic process that we're going to get when we run a random tester is
some sort of a random walk through this finite state machine.
And so, what we want to ask ourselves is
"Does this random walk have a reasonable probability of executing all the cases?"
And so here, probably the most interesting cases are dequeuing from an empty queue,
enqueuing to a full queue, and then walking around the rest of the states base.
And so, what I've done is, I rig the random tester with some extra static skipping,
so you can tell us about this a little bit--so let's go take a look at that.